Do you deny physiology can guide
evolution? No, I suppose not. That's
good. That means you're you're going
against neodyarwinism because
neodyarwinism says you cannot have
physiology guiding evolution.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation, you will
inshallah be reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you can.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
hope you guys are winning. Sabul
recently had a debate with a professor.
Professor, what's your name? Dave Fina.
Yes. I don't think he's a professor. I
think No, no, he's not. He's what is he?
He's a irrelevant person. He Yeah, he
he's somebody who, let's just say I
invited him to speaker's corner. He's
the sort of person you need to bring
there. You need to go bring him there,
rinse him, take him to the cleaners,
take him to the deep waters, make him
discover himself. That's the idea.
Seemed like he drowned in those waters.
He he didn't come to the UK. He didn't
turn up at the debate. I I paid for him
to come down. It was actually funded by
another brother and two brothers
actually. And he never came down. He was
a coward. And then we did an online
debate instead. So that debate has been
going around everywhere now. And Okay.
What's his name? What's his guy? I don't
know nothing about him. Yeah. So he's
basically someone who I I showed you
like he's got three something million
subscribers. Yeah. What was it? Yeah. So
he basic Dave Fina he makes educational
videos. So like for teenagers, for
university, college students, you know,
how to pass exams, you know, go over
this, this, this, all the basic stuff,
right? Um you know that just generic
content which no one disagrees with
basic educ. Then in between he starts
making reputation videos. So he made a
video against me and Muslim Lantern. I
challenged him to a debate. He
challenged him to three debates. He only
accepted one and that one we did just
this weekend. Okay. Fantastic. Well,
okay. Let's see how that went. Uh, let's
see how the professor done. Let's see.
Do you deny physiology can guide
evolution?
Uh, no, I suppose not. Okay, that's good
because that means you're you're going
against neodyarwinism because
neodyarwinism says you cannot have
physiology guiding evolution.
Uh, well, I didn't. Neodyarwinism is not
the current paradigm of evolution. And
that's going to be a very nice short, by
the way. Look, look at look at his
facial expression, bro. He looks
arrogant as well. He looks he looks a
bit like apus. Ooh, bro. He does. But
but but but he's
apos. But yeah, this guy is um Yeah,
he's a particular creature. But do you
know what? During the debate, he was
domesticated. He said um cuz we've been
studying this with Dennis Noble and um
Comrade Wington the rest. So they say
that um uh what is it? Physiology.
Physiology can can can change the the
direction of evolution. It can change
the genome and that is the total
opposite of um neodyinism. Yeah. Of
course. Exactly. And he admit and he
accept anyway he goes. Yeah. He's open
to that. So how can like he didn't he
didn't understand is a trap question,
right? If you're admitting to the idea
that phys physiology can guide
evolution, that means neonism is dead.
Yeah. It's like saying to a Christian,
you know, do you accept that there's a
possibility that the one true God is the
father? And he goes, "Yeah." Do you deny
the idea that um is it possible for you
that the Holy Ghost didn't exist? Yeah,
it's possible. Okay. There's no trinity.
Something like this. Now, it's
interestingly, we've been studying
Dennis Noble. You've been using his
arguments. So have I others. And you
know even though he's not a religious
person you know he's a secular academic
you know he is somebody who has no
credentials no PhD no peer-reviewed uh
academic papers yet he calls Dennis
Noble like a complete clown. What are
the only clown here isn't
I asked him for the evidence. He didn't
have a single piece of evidence he's a
clown. Well let's let's see some more.
the standard idea of the modern
synthesis which in 1976 was really
popularized by the selfish gene book.
Now it goes back to between the 1920s
to50s. You thought it was the 1990s
which itself I said that off the cuff if
I even did say that off the cuff in a
reaction video. It's not like I did a
piece off the cuff. Yeah, you're
referencing the reaction video where I
made fun of you and your friend past
this specific point and focus on Okay.
Were you wrong about that? I don't even
think I said it. This is hard for people
to believe. Like what on earth is an
anti-darwinian evolutionist? So anyway,
in that video, what we do is we put in
the clip where he does actually say it,
right? He says neodyarwinism came
together in the 1920s and the other
modern synthesis came 70 years later.
That equivalently, and I said this in
the debate, is like someone saying World
War I took place in the 1960s.
Everybody knows that makes no sense cuz
that's you're basically saying JFK Yeah.
was killed at the same time that Hitler
was in the trenches. Makes no sense,
right? Historically, let's check. For
physiology to guide evolution, it would
have to change the DNA. What? Say that
again. For physiology to guide
evolution, it would have to change the
DNA. In embryionic development, it's the
genes that are determining the form.
You're talking about mind and body,
right? It's forming the organism, right?
Okay. Okay. Have you heard of somatic
hypermutation?
What about it? No. No. Firstly, have you
heard of it?
Yes, I've heard of it. I don't recall
the exact definition. Can you explain it
to me before I explain it to you and
educate you for free again
in E cells in the immune system and then
I just I just go on and explain I I I
did this throughout the debate. I was
like, "Do you know this, bro? His
reaction, you know, that's why it's very
important to ask questions, bro. His
reactions, bro. He He acts so cocky."
Some some of the videos I've seen, he
acts so cocky and bro, one question
literally the moment when he was like,
"Oh, okay." He knows he doesn't know.
Yeah, he knows he doesn't know. They
don't know. It's going to happen again.
Clown. What a clown. Yeah. Noble is an
Oxford professor, which is something
prestigious, something that Fina can
never be. Maybe that's why he attacked.
He's not an evolutionary biologist,
though. He is an evolutionary biologist.
No, he isn't. You can Google it.
Let's Google it. Is Dennis evolution
biologist?
It's kind of shocking that you didn't
know that. Oh my god. Are you aware of
the distinction between reductive
biology and integrative biology or
holistic biology? Are you aware of the
distinction between the two? I am not
aware of these uh terms that you're that
you're using. No. Go ahead. Okay. So
reductive biology is this idea that you
break everything down to the genetic
level. We did then okay that's the
standard geneentric perspective. Dennis
Noble, Ray Noble, James Shapiro, Scott
Turner, all of these people from the
third way, they believe in the holistic
perspective. They believe that you
simply don't break everything down to
the genetic level. You can actually have
a holistic understanding in which there
is no privileged level of causality. He
gets angry here. Okay. So you can't you
cannot say genes are working at a
privileged level. Now Sydney Brena and
what is a privileged level? What does
that mean? Don't lecture me. We're
talking here. No, I'm educating you. Are
you aware of epigenetics leading to
genetic assimilation? And one of the
causes of that is extracellular
visticles. Now, genetic assimilation is
the final point which Dennis Noble uses
to show that physiology guides
evolution. That is the argument that he
actually makes. And in fact, he's
published a paper on physiology guiding
evolution and also the physiology of
evolution. So, I'm not sure why you keep
saying he's not an evolutionary
biologist. Which one's not Dennis Noble?
Because he's not. I don't like what are
you not understanding about about that?
I I think the basic issue here is you
have confused an assertion for an
argument. You just keep stating, but you
don't give a shred of evidence why he's
not a biologist. Epigenetic.
Universal common ancestor was an idea
that goes back hundreds of years, well
over a thousand years. So Darwinian
evolution to believe in the mechanism of
natural selection and random mutations
creating mind and body has nothing to do
with the history of life. You could
believe in the bush of life. You could
believe in the net of life. You could
believe in the tree of life. It doesn't
actually matter. It is not that's why we
get other evidence. It is not a
necessary and sufficient condition to
believe in common ancestry. Therefore,
Darwinian evolution is true. This is a
nonsequator fallacy. That's why we get
other evidence. You're not understanding
my point. You can believe in common
ancestry and reject Darwinism. Do you
agree with that point? Yeah. You can
reject certain mechanisms again and
again. He's just being educated. Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely. I mean, I mean,
doesn't this show you that that it's
like atheism is on its way out?
Absolutely. And I think a lot of people
are actually turning towards religions
of some sort, new age spirituality and
all sorts of stuff. Islam's on the rise.
And even people who say they're
atheists, they still say, "I believe in
some higher power." You know, this, you
know, that guy that you the Minecraft
guy that you bumped into, he is the
embodiment of the Western psyche
currently, which is atheism's dead. Let
me just paint myself as a Minecraft
character and walk around central
London. Do you believe in God? This that
that's all it is. And genuinely I felt
in the conversation he was giving you
the standard narrative randomness. This
this this this and these guys they don't
realize they've lost the generation.
People don't believe in them anymore.
Nope. They're on their way out. And this
guy's a fine example of that. He has no
he doesn't have has no idea what the
flip is talking about. You can see his
expressions. Yeah. He got he got
schooled. He got educated. He's the one
that's a clown to be honest, you know.
Um and yeah, I mean it's fantastic. It's
to see the end of them. Subhan Allah.
They came with this hype and subhan
Allah. It's it's on its way out and
people are turning back to religion.
Yes. And Islam is on the rise and yes,
Hob is a listen to him, you know, and
Islam is always there for him if he
wants to accept Islam, you know. Um and
yeah, I mean yeah, I mean overall people
like this, they should stop pretending
to be so brave and cocky. You saw the
other videos that I was showing you of
the guy like how is he talking and this
and that. And here look at his facial
expressions. You could just tell we look
we deal with these people in speaker
corner. We've been going there for over
10 years. We can tell when someone's
lost it. It tells the body language.
That's one of the first feedbacks I got.
The guy body language wise. Yeah.
Reminds me of um cosmic skeptic
destroying David Wood. Like it's it's
like that. Absolutely. Absolutely. You
get that. You get that. Yeah. Exactly.
And he has the audacity to call
academics like Dennis Noble, James
Shapiro, and others clowns. He's a
clown, bro. This guy's a clown. You can
say it. I mean, yeah. I hope you guys
enjoyed that, bro. Inshallah. Um yeah.
Until next time.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said whoever builds a masjid for the
sake of Allah subhanaa tala Allah will
build for him a similar house in Jenna
on that day where Allahhana tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atom weight of good deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a masjid. I never had the money to
build a masjid. Oh Allah, you helped.
You gave towards it and Allah gives you
the reward of as if you've built it.
Donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra rewards.
[Music]